sir I know that I got you know hello I'm
deathless frog call a national attention
CEO here I like the answer question from
a living waters please tell us what you
care about what future direction you see
you will contribute improving the state
of the world well Allen they just got
out of a session but we talked about
what rule company should play in society
and that is what I'm really passionate
about learn say one of the things that's
great you've got all these resources go
get all these great companies that can
do all these wonderful things and we've
been focused on profits which are
critical there's a social side needs to
be addressed as well so moving forward I
like to really help through our actions
show other companies how we can actually
change the world through our our
prophets and our social responsibility
as organizations so you also ask how
we're going to do that well one of the
things we're doing is an organization
called everyone gets out you can help us
change the world as well in order to
improve the state of the world februari
22nd 2012 I'd like everybody to get on a
website everyone gives org and donate
five dollars to the charity of their
choice after you do that I'd like you to
tell two friends and then I'd like you
ask them to tell two friends and
together we can go about changing the
world thank you for your question